after all the hype guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 proved itself a worthy
successor to the first film with another
awesome mixtape blasting and another
round of adventures for star-lord and
his gang of unlikely heroes vol 2
offered up the same mix of action and
comedy fans have come to love and like
the first installment the newest
guardians is packed with Easter eggs
here are all the details only two fans
noticed in guardians of the galaxy two
major spoilers ahead retro tracker one
of the very first shots of the movie
shows star-lord tracking the ability the
giant space octopus on a very retro
looking piece of hardware it looks about
the 21st century of Star Wars or some
mixtapes and for good reason that space
alien tracker is literally just a
mottled electronics classic football
game if you squint during the movie you
can even see a faded Mattel electronics
written across the top glimpse of
eternity when ego forces his will on to
his son and Peter's eyes fill with stars
Peter whispers one word eternity sir
casual fans it sounds like he's saying
basically man that's a big universe but
it also seems like a reference to a
god-like being from the comics in the
Marvel Universe eternity is a character
who encompasses everything in the
universe of being with tremendous cosmic
powers remember how ego is kind of a god
but with a little g-well eternity is the
big G one of them anyway in Marvel terms
star-lord got himself a glimpse of God
heavy Grandmaster surprise one of the
best surprises in the Thor Ragnarok
trailer was the appearance of Jeff
Goldblum as the Grandmaster and if you
thought you'd have to wait until
November to see him in action you're in
luck
Goldblum makes a brief or dancing cameo
in the credits of guardians of the
galaxy - which doesn't serve any purpose
or we can tell but it's a nice nod for
the coming clash of worlds happening in
the MCU Gallagher tactics when the
sovereign drone ships attack the
guardians we get even more proof that
writer director James Gunn is completely
in love with the 80s the drones attack
into streaming lines a pitch-perfect
flight plan from the original Gallagher
arcade game even
weapons sounds pretty familiar and when
all the sovereign pods explode in the
quantum asteroid field except one the
pilots gather around the last remaining
Starfighter just like kids in an arcade
Planet Hulk after their encounter with
the drones the guardians are forced to
make an emergency landing on an empty
planet the place fills up pretty fast
though as both ego and the Ravagers
track the guardians to the planet's
surface
but if Quillin crew had spent a little
more time walking around those woods
they may have seen that they weren't a
first voyages to crash land and that
forest in fact they might have been able
to see a big hole sized footprint on the
ground
that's because burr hurt the planet they
landed on is apparently the same one
where Hulk fought the galaxy master in
Incredible Hulk number 111 there's even
a race that lives there the Sagittarians
contracts here nobody's making of planet
names for Guardians just about every
planet that shows up relates to one
that's already been established in
Marvel Comics that includes contracts
here the planets where yondu makes his
first appearance in the film the first
time Marvel readers saw contracts here
was in Jack of Hearts number 2 and it
served as a setting for Jack's
adventures for 3 issues the planet
showed up again in Marvel Zombies
Suprema volume 1 and number 4 which saw
Jack of Hearts returning to fight the
undead squadron supreme like in
guardians the contracts here of the
comics is cold and bleak the kind of
place where you're bound to run into an
unsavory character or two speaking of
which how would the duck volume 2 ah
Howard that's it no more mr. nice duck
the star of a terrible movie but an
awesome Easter egg in both Guardians
movies how would return some guardians
vol 2 this time relaxing with a drink on
contracts eeeh the camera slides past
him pretty quickly so you have to keep
an eye out for him how would the duck
might seem like an odd choice to second
guardians of the galaxy but to James
Gunn if the duck fits its sense gun told
Yahoo movies in March 2017 that he's a
huge Howard the Duck fan well a huge fan
of Howard the Duck comic stutters like
the rest of humanity
for the movie from the 80s sucked we'll
just have to wait until volume 3 to see
what the duck shows up next original
guardians guardians vol 2 featured a ton
of new faces but for those who have kept
up with the comics over the years most
of them weren't actually new at all
so faster Stallone's characters Picaro
God first appeared in 1975 in defenders
number 27
he becomes star hawk and joins the
guardians and the first issues of their
1990 run during your news epic
Technicolor funeral we also get to see
Charlie 27 Aleta Oh God and Martin
expand agar who also showed up on
contract SIA in the movie these
characters were all involved with the
older and original incarnations of the
guardians of the galaxy team the
post-credits scenes also gives us a
glimpse of Kruger who in the comics
becomes dr. Strange's apprentice either
Gunn is just paying tribute to the old
guardians or they'll all be back in vol
3 again we'll have to wait and see Adam
warlock one of the final Easter eggs in
the movie came during one of the
post-credits scenes ie shared a
sovereign's leader and vales a golden
cocoon that contains a man she only
refers to as Adam longtime fans of the
comics realized pretty quickly that she
was talking about Adam warlock a
mainstay of Marvel's cosmic comics like
in the movie Adam was created inside a
cocoon in the comics and grew to become
an incredibly powerful character after
taking possession of one of the Infinity
stones what his role will be in the MCU
and the upcoming infinity war is still
uncertain but it's definitely going to
be a game changer
Stan the delivery man playing a game of
spot the stan is always fun and the
Guardians too doesn't disappoint but the
plot thickens when we see Stanley
talking to the watches of rocket and
yondu a portal jumping across the galaxy
he tells him about his job as a FedEx
delivery man you know which was totally
his job in Captain America Civil War are
you Tony
stank yes this is this is Tony stank
you're in the right place on one hand it
makes for a messy eater egg with in an
Easter Egg moment on the other hand it's
possible confirmation of a long-held fun
theory
Stanley is a watcher himself an alien
being that observes momentous events in
the Marvel Universe even in light of
that evidence the studio still isn't
explicitly confirming that theory but
think about it every one of these movies
covers a major event so by Marvel logic
there's probably a watcher
somewhere in each of those movies
someone who always shows up and always
looks the same and has no other reason
to be there
someone like Stanley only came back
Stanley never left and I'm starting to
think that his mind is no longer in mint
condition thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to